nous sommes en algérie depuis moins de
24 heures
direction le siège social de snc lavalin
à alger la capitale mais les agents de
sécurité ne vous empêche de films la
police doit intervenir pour calmer le
jeu snc-lavalin obtient si d'importants
contrats depuis des années mais de toute
évidence la firme n'est pas habitué à ce
que les médias posent des questions
[Musique]
moins d'une heure plus tard la police
nous interpelle alors que nous filmons
des images général d'alger il nous amène
sous escorte au commissariat de police
c'est monnaie courante répression
emprisonnements arbitraires
licenciements annoncés c'est horrible ce
que nous subissons depuis 15 ans la
police et les militaires sont partout
ils surveillent contrôler interviennent
constamment le gouvernement algérien
nous a pourtant accordé un des rares
visa de presse
en sachant que nous venions enquêter sur
les contrats de snc lavalin presque
chaque fois nous sortirons notre caméra
il faudra affronter les autorités ça
c'est des pratiques propres régimes à un
gouvernement autoritaire répressif et
policiers qui n'est pas il n'est pas un
gouvernement démocratique
bienvenue en algérie
[Musique]
cet homme surnommé l'homme qui parle
trop a été arrêté plus de cent fois il a
été menacé de mort et emprisonné depuis
quinze ans il dirige l'association
algérienne contre la corruption un
travail risqué parce que les grands
scandales économiques en algérie sont
souvent liées au gouvernement et à la
toute puissante armée algérienne
on a mis en parallèle le classement des
dix premiers pays qui sont les plus
transparents en matière de lutte contre
la corruption et on a mis en parallèle
un autre classement qui est un
classement algérien quels sont les dix
pays avec qui l'algérie commerce et à
des relations économiques aucun des dix
pays les moins corrompus nkok ne
commerciaux tollé de marché avec avec
l'algérie donc là les 1000g d'y aller
mais c'est comme si nous disions dix
mois avec quel pays tu commets je dirais
c'est vrai qu'on rompe non pas l'algérie
est riche riche en hydrocarbures
l'or noir rapporte de 70 milliards de
dollars par année à l'état qui contrôle
la ressource presque le tiers du pétrole
consommé au québec provient d'algérie
depuis 15 ans 400 milliards de dollars
ont servi à bâtir des infrastructures
une manne pour les compagnies étrangères
un terreau fertile pour la corruption
nous avons été amenés à être contacté
par des entreprises étrangères qui
avaient été éliminés pour des raisons un
peu obscur des témoignages extrêmement
accablant pratiquement je me le dit
j'assume je suis mes propos aucune
entreprise aucun grand projet
n'échappant n'a échappé à des versements
de pots-de-vin et de commissions à
partir d'un certain niveau de contrat et
dans le domaine pétrolier en particulier
il est impossible d'obtenir un contre
sens payé un pot-de-vin quelque part c
c'est devenu c'est pratiquement
institutionnalisée
cet homme aussi dérange parce qu'ils
dénoncent la corruption en algérie
il vit à paris et son livre l'histoire
secrète du pétrole algérien est interdit
en algérie
c'est un ancien dirigeant de sonatrach
la société nationale des hydrocarbures
il explique comment les contrats sont
obtenus grâce à des ententes secrètes
avec des ministres et surtout avec des
généraux de l'armée
mes contrats pétroliers c'est
l'entreprise de pétrole y sont signés
c'est le pdg de la sonatrach qui
lui-même en réfère aux ministres et par
conséquent bon l'ordre viennent d'en
haut d'accord pour la valeur ou aller
signer avec laval a évidemment lors des
trans new d'abord aux ministres qui le
répercute sur le pdg de la sonatrach qui
lui-même le répercute sur le l'ingénieur
en charge du projet ainsi tué un chat
qui se met en place
c'est ainsi qu'un groupe sélect de
compagnies étrangères obtient des
contrats avec le gouvernement
snc lavalin en fait partie et pas faire
des affaires d'or
ici j'ai comme l'impression qu'à
l'intérieur de la valeur c'est une
coutume qui existe depuis longtemps
parce que dès que l'aval est arrivé en
algérie
déjà lors du premier contrat il ya eu
des pots-de-vin qui ont été pays
ce premier contrat de laval est en
algérie remonte à 1981 c'est ce monument
symbole de l'indépendance du pays
une prouesse technique réalisée par une
équipe de québécois tels que le rappelle
ce vidéos corporatifs de la firme
quelques heures avant son inauguration
l'imposant bâtiment est terminée ça a
été un défi incroyable des gens
travaillaient depuis 8 ans peut être pas
tant un peu le monument sur les hauteurs
d'alger attire encore aujourd'hui les
badauds c'est une maladie a été impliqué
dans ce chantier
il se rappelle que ses supérieurs
avaient tenté de lui forcer la main pour
accorder un contrat à laval est un
contrat pour lequel la firme n'était pas
qualifié selon lui je subis des
pressions bon congédiement il tout
contrat ne peut être imposée avec l'aval
en enfance était clair que j'avais des
commissions au bout parce que sinon
pourquoi quelqu'un qui ne connaît pas le
secteur qui ne connaît pas le métier
bien se mêler et vous dire prenez telle
entreprise
si ce n'est pour des raisons comme
celle-là lavalin était alors dirigée par
bernard lamarre
l'aîné de la famille aujourd'hui
retraité malade il nous a accordé une
entrevue au téléphone il nie avoir donné
des poudres est mon apport virtuel de
poèmes de voir ce qu'on doit là c'était
surtout une diffusion des idées
pourtant cet ancien colonel du drs
l'équivalent algérien de la cia nous
affirme le contraire il soutient que le
drs avait fait enquête et obtenu des
preuves de cette corruption
c'est connu ça fait connu que c'est
pâques ou non non c'est l'enquète avait
été à l'époque entamée par les services
de renseignements algériens qui avait
qui étaient parvenus à des pistes
probables matériel et à ce moment là
ss et la valeur si vous continuez nous
allons donner la liste des bénéficiaires
des commissions et il ya eu des
instructions à l'époque pour dire stop
et l'umq est ils ont fait arrêter langue
est dans son nouveau politique donc l'
enquête a été arrêté jeudi des
instructions avaient été données pour
que des enquêtes soient stoppés elle a
été stoppée
de son côté bernard lamarre doute qu'une
enquête était démuni je me suis évanoui
pendant des années la valley et ensuite
snc lavalin lors de la fusion des
entreprises vont continuer à travailler
en algérie sans être inquiété
mais aujourd'hui elle a rendez-vous avec
la justice algérienne début des années
2000 le prix du pétrole explose
l'état algérien lancent de grands
chantiers en dix ans snc lavalin option
pour quatre milliards de dollars un
contrat sous la supervision de sami ben
et bah oui ici au barrage de taksebt
sami ben oui singh en 2005 un contrat de
750 millions de dollars
il s'agit de construire une station de
traitement des eaux est d'acheminer
l'eau potable dans des tuyaux
souterrains jusqu'à alger à 90 km
snc lavalin s'associe aux entreprises de
tony accurso pour réaliser ce projet
aujourd'hui le chantier est terminé nous
est propre il parvient à la capitale
mais le contrat lui est en nous
troublent tony accurso et deux de ses
entreprises sont accusées de fraude
fiscale par le ministère du revenu du
québec
les enquêteurs ont trouvé pour 2
millions de dollars de fausses factures
attribué à ce projet nous avons
questionné la direction de snc lavalin à
montréal le nouveau vice président de la
division construction qu'a fait carrière
à la firme revient tout juste d'algérie
il ignore où est passé l'argent
alors s'il ya eu des choses qu'on
connaît pas qui ont été organisées par
des personnes des ex-employés avec avec
ce maillot du centre c'est pas ça c'est
le manque est qu'ils veulent qu'ils
veulent démontrer
vous avez vous pas pu vous apercevoir au
moment la réception des factures qu'il y
avait peut-être des choses et pense là
dedans je peux vous assurer si on savait
qu'il y avait ils fausses factures ou
autres en ont réagi en conséquence bien
sûr jamais qu'on a été au courant de ça
ou quand même soupçons naissants
et pourtant plusieurs personnes qui ont
travaillé à snc nous ont révélé que des
dépenses injustifiées de plus de 10
millions $ ont été faites sur ce
chantier entre autres pour l'achat de
voitures de luxe dont certaines ont été
livrés à l'extérieur de l'algérie et du
canada nous ne sommes pas la police mais
concernant le projet de taxe est par
exemple on a plus parlé à différentes
personnes
j'imagine que snc-lavalin vous pouvez
quand même questionné les gens au sein
des scènes cela valait pour voir qu'est
ce qui s'est passé mais limoges jeu peu
emballant de tous ces détails que vous
avez mais s'ils sont des allégations
c'est juste les enquêtes qui vont
pouvoir le couvrir je peux pas commenter
ces informations
de l'argent du projet de taksebt se
serait retrouvé sur des comptes à genève
dans deux coquilles vides appartenant à
sami ben et bah oui il a été interrogé
par la justice suisse à ce sujet et si
on devait fouiller davantage et les sûr
qu'entre en scène c'est là-bas main et
j'allais dire les entreprises
algériennes qui ont comme qui ont signé
des démarches et des grands entretiens
aux chaînes et marseille car il ya une
faune d'intermédiaires le différents
pays européens du moyen orient qui ont
joué les intermédiaires pour faire en
sorte aussi qu'il ya les versements des
propos d'autres lucratifs contrats
suivent centrale électrique au gaz
1.3 milliards de dollars 1.2 milliard
pour une autre usine de traitement du
gaz en plein milieu du désert
les affaires vont bien trop bien pour
être dans les règles
selon cet employé toujours chez snc
lavalin et qui bien au fait de ce qui se
passait en afrique du nord
snc lavalin était très choyé pour le
nombre de contrats qu'ils obtenaient en
algérie il dépassait toute normalité en
termes de contrats obtenus par rapport à
ceux soumissionner exemple un très bon
estimateur va gagner à peu près 10% des
contrats et en algérie on obtenait plus
de 90% des contrats auxquels vous
soulignez auxquels nous sommes ici
oignons est ce un taux de succès de 90%
c'est sa part anormale
c'est effectivement normal le secret de
ce succès est découvert à des milliers
de kilomètres d'alger admis l'an alors
que les italiens enquête sur les
pots-de-vin qu aurait versé leur
entreprise pétrolière en algérie il
découvre que snc lavalin aurait fait la
même chose
le journaliste enquête claudio gatti
explique la façon de faire jean et wind
farm boy pays compagnie delpire
guillaume d'ingénieurs versé de l'argent
à des compagnies écran aux îles vierges
britanniques créé par un bureau
d'avocats au panama ces compagnies sont
des coquilles vides avec des comptes de
banque en suisse
bedjaoui distribuer ensuite l'argent
c'est lui qui se cachait derrière ces
compagnies au coeur du stratagème un
personnage mystérieux farid bedjaoui
diplômé d hec à montréal citoyen
canadien
farid bedjaoui sert d'intermédiaire pour
l'entreprise italienne et aussi pour
snc-lavalin les italiens y aurait versé
280 millions de dollars pour brouiller
les pistes
bedjaoui se sert de deux sociétés écrans
minko goût des dizaines de millions ont
été retracés mais selon mes informations
snc lavalin aurait payé autant que les
italiennes
les deux compagnies de bedjaoui ont été
incorporés en 2004 tout juste avant la
signature du contrat de t'accepte snc
lavalin n'aurait pas retracer ce réseau
de sociétés écran ni les paiements
effectués et vous venez ici vous voudrez
sur ces derniers sur farid bedjaoui
lançant je vous dis je vous dis la
vérité je ne sais pas si les enquêtes
que vous pouvez nous nous démontrer qu
est-ce qui c'était quoi les liens ou
qu'est ce qu'il ya eu dont il faut pas
présumer de quoi que ce soit encore en
algérie où il n'a jamais habité farid
bedjaoui est le neveu de l'ancien
ministre des affaires étrangères et son
véritable contact et le ministre de
l'énergie lui même pour qu'il aurait
collecté des pots-de-vin compagnie
le président de la firme italienne
accusé de corruption a affirmé dans un
témoignage avoir rencontré le ministre
de l'énergie algérien à paris et que
celui ci lui aurait présenté
farid bedjaoui comme son assistant
au québec des gens de snc lavalin ils
ont révélé avoir fait affaire avec farid
bedjaoui qui étaient surtout liées aux
deux anciens vice président nous le
disons haut responsable c'est la balance
ce ne sont pas des actes isolés
ce ne sont pas le comportement d'un vice
président ou d'un responsable c'est
malheureusement il faudrait faire le
constat ce sera très douloureux pour
snc-lavalin si elle sénégalais va avoir
un avenir des perspectives c'est que
c'est une pratique j'allais dire qui
pratiquement systémique au niveau du
groupe pas en canada pour à l'étranger
trois fois un groupe d'employés a écrit
des lettres anonymes à la haute
direction à montréal pour dénoncer les
pratiques douteuses qui auraient encore
cours au sein de la firme en algérie en
vain le nom de farid bedjaoui était
mentionné
des employés locaux nous ont contactés
secrètement pour nous en parler me
semble que moi on entre en algérie
jarret mais sans rencontrer en privé
qu'est ce que vous savez de ce gala
qu'est ce qu'on a fait avec lui
qu'est-ce qu'on a signé avec lui mais je
suis en plus je voulais m'en souvenais
on le fait et vous posez des questions
qui a fait affaire avec paris de
bedjaoui qu'est ce qu'on sait de lui les
employés sont libres de s'exprimer ils
sont libres de venir me rencontrer quand
ils veulent
ma porte est toujours ouverte en algérie
personne qui m'a parlé de monsieur vidéo
l'enquète italienne force la main à la
justice algérienne
quatre jours avant notre passage le drs
avait perquisitionné au siège social de
snc lavalin alger on a fouillé on a
regardé on essayait de savoir aussi un
on adore on a fait tout seul
mais notre capacité de savoir et
illimité quand même c'est pour çà
entendre beaucoup sur les autorités
soient algérienne ou canadiennes pour
connaître la vérité
l'algérie enquête sur cette centrale qui
produit de l'électricité à partir du gaz
snc lavalin aurait profité davantage qui
font sourciller terrain arabe et
exemptions d'impôts et surtout le gaz
lui est fourni gratuitement
l'algérie s'est même engagé à lui
acheter sa production toute sa
production pendant 20 ans cela en rage
ce cadre de la société algérienne
d'électricité qui doit fermer deux de
ses propres centrales pour cause de
surproduction
vous prenez tout ce que je peux produire
et ce même si vous ne prenez pas vous du
pays
ça ressemble un petit peu si jamais par
exemple mcdonald's céréales et vient
chez vous au canada
sûrement il existe il vient chez vous il
vous dit bon vous arrêter vous mangez
plus vos conduits vous devriez manger
tout ce que je peux produire hombourg la
même chose en art et man centrale
c'est dans son tweet on arrête et on
doit manger que la production les
hamburgers que à saint séraphin nombreux
la faire snc lavalin est hautement
médiatisé et mais les gouvernements
algérien et un canadien dans l'embarras
lors d'une visite récente en algérie le
ministre canadien des affaires
étrangères a publiquement pris ses
distances avec snc-lavalin le canada
joue gros en algérie je pense que si des
enquêtes en cours ne sont pas suivies de
résultats l'avenir économique et je peux
dire même politique et diplomatique du
canada avec l'algérie est compromis
est-ce que vous pouvez soumissionner
actuellement d'agir ils n'ont
actuellement actuellement en cours de l'
enquête en cours on nous a informés que
l'on peut pas soumissionner sur certains
projets tant que l' enquête n'a pas été
compliqué
la justice italienne a lancé un mandat
international contre le ministre
algérien d'énergie il a quitté l'algérie
en douce et vit ici à washington
farid bedjaoui l'intermédiaire canadien
s'est réfugié dans son palace à dubaï
il possède aussi un bateau de 25
millions de dollars dans cette marina un
mandat d'arrêt international pèse aussi
contre lui
sami ben oui l'ancien vice président de
snc lavalin vit lui aussi à dubaï
à quelques centaines de mètres de là son
avocat craint pour sa liberté s'il
revient au canada j'attends du
gouvernement canadien de la justice
canadien dans le plus police judiciaire
canadienne à ce qu'ils puissent
réellement tourner cette page
ça ne peut plus continuer comme ça ce
pillage en règle
la grc a saisi plusieurs immeubles
appartenant à sami ben oui et ses
enfants elle soupçonne qu'une partie de
l'argent sale a été recyclée à montréal
aucune accusation n'a encore été portée
donc union publique algérienne
mais tous ses espoirs dans un justice
canadien des algériens disent de toute
manière du côté du canada l'enquète ne
se terminera pas comme ça snc lavalin
opèrent encore des installations en
algérie mais aucun nouveau contrat là
même de l'eau au moulin et nous notre
politique
maintenant c'est si ça prend des pots de
vin on peut le faire mais peu faible
contre celle que ça il y en a qui vont
dire baisse et la vanne et gagnera
jamais aucune soumission oui ce sera
d'autres entreprises étrangères qui vont
nuire à travailler ailleurs
qu'est ce que vous lui si on payera pas
ce prix là pour gagner un contrat on
préfère perdre contre 1 plutôt que payer
quelqu'un pour la voir
il ya plus de 30 ans l'algérie a donné à
snc-lavalin sa première chance
internationale le paradoxe c'est
qu'aujourd'hui ce pays pourrait lui
porter le coup le plus dur
[Musique]